hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Game of Thrones Q&A you know
mostly questions about what's going on
with Sansa and Ramsay but there were
like a couple really big ones that
everyone had so I'll just start with
those careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet so starting
with Littlefinger and Ramsay a lot of
people were wondering whether or not
Littlefinger was lying when he said he
didn't know anything about him
Littlefinger is the master of lies so I
think he has an idea of what's going on
with Ramsay I think he's heard things he
might not know the whole story but he
probably understands that he is very
dangerous so I think that moment when he
said I haven't heard anything about you
was completely disingenuous he was just
throwing a smoke screen at Ramsay and
Ramsay himself was also lying through
his teeth when he said he would take
great care of Sansa no surprise that
everybody's lying here we go next
question Sam's Finch asks so if Sansa
and Ramsay are getting married there
will have to be a wedding right yeah I
mean it would be very mean of the show
to tease us with a wedding and then not
actually show it so I think there will
be some sort of ceremony because Tommen
and Marjorie's wedding seem so normal I
think we can expect the crazy wedding
this season to be Sansa Ramsay there
were actually a bunch of other questions
that like went into specific details
about this
so we'll just parse through Sansa Ramsay
as we go through the qat
it's gonna be a lot of fun this is
actually gonna be one of the most
interesting storylines despite being
vastly different from the books next
question Cioffi asks am I the only one
that kind of sees Littlefinger as a
snake type character not that
Littlefinger will ever redeem himself
Wow you don't say you don't sound very
hopeful about Littlefinger it does seem
like he has the best of intentions with
respect to Sansa but he does have some
some other grand gold that she's only a
part of I've also seen a lot of
questions as to whether or not
Littlefinger really wants to sit on the
Iron Throne like it's clear that he
wants to get rid of the Lannisters he
wants to depose the current rulers but I
think what he really wants is just the
power he doesn't want the actual throne
itself like if he ends up being
successful he won't care who sits on the
Iron Throne as long as he's like the new
Tywin Lannister it's kinda like what's
going on with Faris's character he wants
to restore another ruler to the throne
he doesn't necessarily want to sit on it
himself although other two I would say
Varys is much more altruistic although
we really don't know the full extent of
what his intentions are
all we know is that he wants to nurse on
the throne we don't know what he's gonna
do after that if he's successful
I think of Littlefinger had his way he
would probably put Sansa on the throne
just because he knows that he has a
relationship with her
she'll at least listen to him whether or
not she actually trusts him next
question she no baqia desks why can't
the Bolton's just arrest Littlefinger
and Sansa
hold them hostage and forced the north
to obey but I think the problem is is
that it Roose wants to keep the north
and if he wants them to like him like he
has to be able to work with them he
can't replace all the people that live
in the north if he were to imprison or
kill Sansa they would immediately turn
on him
the only reassurance of control that he
had before came from Tywin Lannister
Tywin Lannister controlled all the money
all the troops now that he's gone roost
does not have that guarantee anymore so
he needs to find another source of
support that's the opportunity
Littlefinger used to form an alliance
with him next question Carolin asks when
Ramsay was talking to Littlefinger he
said I'll never hurt her but we know he
can be a liar do you think that he will
hurt her or maybe his partner crime will
hurt her in some way so what I think is
gonna happen is is Miranda will probably
take some shots at her I mean I think
they want you to think that Ramsay is
gonna do something terrible to Sansa
this might be one of those situations
where they like bait-and-switch you
where it's like Ramsay's terrible
clearly he's going to turn Sansa into
his new reek cut to shocking twist and
in Game of Thrones fashion as for what
that twist could be it could be anything
what I'd really like to see is Sansa cut
Ramsay's sausage off like on their
wedding night like some some crazy WTF
moment like that if certain events on
the show seem like they're building
towards similar moments that we've seen
before
it's on purpose like we're building
towards another red wedding type moment
we're building towards another reek type
moment so the twist would be is that you
know some torture is visited upon Ramsay
himself that's just speculation though I
just I feel like that would be a fun way
to close Ramsay's storyline if he ended
up losing his sausage next question
rubin asks do you think that aria will
stop training with the faceless men
because she can't kills those she wants
and she can't lick over past so I think
this is getting into like you know Meryn
Trant
mace Tyrell territory Meryn Trant is on
her list and he is escorting mace Tyrell
to Braavos so what I'm hoping is as they
bump into each
there he doesn't recognize her but she
recognizes him and tries to get revenge
for what happened to Syrio Forel it's
possible that she could have to like
choose between killing Meryn Trant and
doing something else that Jack and asked
her to do next question Mario asks are
you excited or nervous to see how the
show has changed Sansa Jaime and Brienne
storylines from the books yes I mean
there's some really interesting things
that they could give them I think what's
gonna happen is they'll graft storylines
from other characters on to their
characters a good example of that is you
know I'm hoping they turn Brienne into
the ghost of Winterfell that storyline
from the books I spent a lot of my
videos you know leading up to the season
talking about dark Sansa so I'm hoping
thumb attica Lee she gets some of the
revenge story art that they gave to Lady
Stoneheart even though she's turning
into more of like a plotter schemer
Littlefinger type character than an
outright stabby character Jaime is still
a bit of a question market and we
haven't seen a lot of his character yet
so I'm gonna hold off on speculation for
him until we get down to Dorne next
question dog-lover asks what do you
think Littlefinger's endgame is now do
you think the writers have changed it
since he's giving up the key to the
north to Roose it seems to be forming an
alliance and instead of going for chaos
well I think that his storyline is still
very similar and that he's trying to
bring down the monarchy it's really hard
to tell where George R Martin is going
in the books it's loosely implied that
Littlefinger just wants to bring
everything crumbling down because
there's so many different plots from so
many different characters trying to put
someone else on the Iron Throne what I'm
hoping is the really big players that
survive all start to form new alliances
with the other big ones so they start to
winnow things down to like two big teams
Littlefinger if he's not successful in
this plot to unite the north and the
Vale he might just try to form an
alliance with Dorne or with Daenerys
I'll be interested to see though if they
do decide to go that Gatsby route with
his character where it's like you know
you get to the final season you know
book seven whatever and he's like I did
this all for you Catelyn while he's
staring at Sansa just just completely
out of his mind
next question though Narwhal asks since
Jorah kidnapped Tyrion what is Lord
Varys his role in the Targaryen
restoration will he travel to marine
yeah I mean he'll probably still make
his way there what I'm hoping is is that
he introduces us to the group that's
behind the Targaryen restoration as far
as we know Daenerys and her inner circle
have their own
plan to retake Westeros at some point
and they're not associated with the
official Targaryen restoration that's
like a secret plot built by a group of
people that we haven't met yet or maybe
we have met them maybe you know maybe
that's part of what the Martell story
lines going to be but yes eventually I
do think that Varys will make his way to
marine next question Pam asks what do
you make of the look the red priestess
in volantis gave to Tyrion well I
actually I had a funny thought you know
like hey I've read book six and seven I
know what happens to you and like she
was laughing at him inside quietly
judging him just because she knew how
different things were gonna be from the
show in the books really though it was
just the same type of look that
Melisandre gives to Jon Snow
she just senses great destiny in him the
visions that the red priests can conjure
in the flames can be interpreted a lot
of different ways so she might not know
exactly who he is only that he is a very
important person for what's to come the
war between the great other and the
forces of the red God because we're
getting to see a lot more of the east
hopefully in future seasons we'll
actually get a deeper dive into the
mythology of the red God it would be
pretty cool to see the inside of one of
the red temples and if you didn't
recognize all right I said something on
Twitter but I didn't include it in my
episode 3 video that's actually Rila
Fukushima from arrow she plays katana on
arrow
she was also ukyo in the wolverine
standalone film next question ivan Wu
asks is pycelle gonna have a huge part
in the future storyline Cersei doesn't
seem to like him anymore
I never read the books but I have a
feeling he's gonna betray Cersei
I definitely think you're onto something
he made that comment where he said you
know a man's private life should remain
private as we saw the sparrows are going
around in dieting everyone they can just
you know grabbing people they think are
doing immoral things getting rid of the
booze pycelle probably has like some
some pervy secrets he doesn't want to
get out that they will find out about
and he'll also be thrown to the wolves
so what happens is like when everyone
starts getting accused of things they
start turning on each other
so yeah I definitely think that pycelle
will do something to try and save
himself whether or not it's informing on
Cersei remains to be seen but remember
Cersei when she was talking to Jaime has
been throwing caution to the wind about
the way she talks about their twincest
and their children please if you have
read the books just use spoiler tags
because I do think they're going to be
doing a lot of Cersei storyline from
book 4 don't be surprised
if there are like scenes from last
season that are mirrored in scenes this
season it just feels like a very TV type
thing for them to do where it's like oh
the same things happening only now it's
happening to someone else
that goes for all the characters though
not not to the characters in King's
Landing thank you everyone for so many
questions so these are always a ton of
fun to do dinner I think we're really
looking forward to what happens between
Sansa and Ramsay it's a big question
mark because it's not in the books but
they could weave some really fun stuff
from Winterfell in the books so I think
barring the hardhome storyline and
what's going on in King's Landing
that'll be like the most interesting
place congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner
Liam Duggan you in an HBO now
subscription be sure to DM me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact info and because the book
giveaway winners still haven't contacted
me what I'm gonna do is is when we get
to episode 5 the books will just be part
of that giveaway so if you won the books
you have two more weeks to DM me if
you're confused as to whether or not you
won the books it's in my episode 1 Q&A
video thank you again everyone that's
been submitting fansubs you guys have
been a huge help while you guys wait for
next week's bonus video I'm still kind
of up in the air about as to what it's
gonna be probably something Martell
related you guys can't click here for my
episode 3 video and you can click here
to learn all about the history of
Winterfell thank you so much for
watching everybody I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives